l'heure n'est plus à la rigolade a
une fois de plus
j'ai été trahi encore partis en fumée
bien alors c'est violent trail du verbe
à travailler dur du verbe genton times
[Rires]
je commence à me faire regretter
pernikoff
[Musique]
quelqu'un sur ce plateau
a une fois de plus en train tenter de
souder soudoyer les équipes sur le test
de culture générale des miss france on
va pousser la violer qu'elle aille au
choix non et quand même j'ai une vidéo
pour preuve
je vais commencer à prendre des
sanctions extrêmement violent en faux
est importante je vous demande est chez
vous de regarder la vidéo juste éloigner
les âmes sensibles
[Musique]
j'en ai chialé juste après
dans la personne qui a fait ça
sachez qu'elle est dans cette rangée
évidemment et sachez que la personne est
née
après 1880
vous pouvez en 17 ans
j'allais droit d'être déjà des trois
c'est bon coup deux
traits de choses
et puis beaucoup de personnes
mais énormément de crème de beauté comme
à la base et
non
pas regarder la vidéo et je pense que
vous allez reconnaître votre voix olala
connard
ça choquant a forcé
ouais ya fabien qui m'a dit qu'il
fallait que je t'appelle
moi je ne sais pas
ouais ouais peut-être ne sais pas là bas
je devrais c'est moi qui ai fait
pourquoi je peux mourir
pour refaire
on va tout sur
écoute et hommes une chose très claire
c'est que jamais je ne te donnerai
réponse
jamais jamais jamais je ne trahirai
cyril et la confiance de cyril
avec deux champions quel match lg oui
désolé ça ne m'intéresse pas
[Applaudissements]
j'avais tous reconnu la voix de
guillaume genton oui oui delphine oui
je commence à comprendre ton choix tu as
tout de suite vu c'est un traître oui
oui c'est un filou et fils je pense que
et voilà il faut que tu redeviennent toi
même c'est important il est lui-même non
ils commencent à un an sont rien en tout
cas vous la banane vous va très bien
ben oui c'est vraiment guillaume genton
chez vous je ne veux pas de salamalecs b
tun la vérité pour une fois pour une
fois montré une photo je vous dis vous
êtes sûrs et celle était d'ailleurs
vous allez être sanctionné doublement
comment doublement
dites moi d'abord votre version alors je
vais expliquer après pourquoi je triche
en ce moment je traverse une période
très difficile
g est ce qui se passe s'il vous plaît tu
commis l'irréparable
et c'est un terrible mal qui me ronge
j'ai envie de payer pour mes erreurs
vous savez j'ai été puni puisque ce soir
je dois à nîmes et rennes le prem et
vous deviez animé la première partie
mais j'ai envie de faire face à mes
responsabilités j'ai envie d'animer tout
le prennent à la fois si vous aviez très
envie de l'animé mais je suis prêt à le
faire ça chez nous mais pourquoi punir
les téléspectateurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]